[Applause]
shaky mobile phone footage from Russian
occupied zaparesia a faint chant of
referendum and a sign saying together
with Russia
in luhanska show of hands in favor of a
vote on joining Russia here in Kirsten
and in Donetsk too even if this is not
in their power to give whatever Russia
says
from the very beginning of the special
military operation but also before it we
have been saying that people of relevant
territories should decide their fate the
current situation confirms that they
want to be the masters of their fate
as far as Russia's talk shows go these
referendum are a done deal dubious
statistics to suggest the majority will
vote Yes in four days of voting
and just in case residents of donbass
who fled or been forced to flee to
Russia will be provided with ballot
boxes here
what this means for Vladimir Putin is
that he can claim this huge chunk of
eastern Ukraine as his own and argue
that any Ukrainian attack is a direct
attack on Russian territory and must be
defended with the full force of the
state whatever that takes
it in the state Parliament legislation
rushed through to expand the criminal
code and circumstances of mobilization
martial law or war words avoided so far
in Russia's so-called special military
operation
I think that actually for Putin his bet
is that the West fearing that it can go
too far and that they will face some
nuclear risks they will push
Ukraine
zielinsky to consider summary treatment
but Ukraine is standing firm and Western
leaders are adamant there is nothing
legitimate to this vote
Russia has declared war it has invaded
the region it has bombarded it it has
killed people it's made people flee now
it is explaining that in this region
it's going to organize a referendum if
it wasn't so tragic we'd laugh the
referendum
S I think is Russia is do is it's an act
of desperation for Russia but it is
it's industry Chiefs on Tuesday telling
them to ramp up production for his
forces at the front but no expected
address to the people Russian State
journalists now say that will take place
on Wednesday
Sky News Moscow